[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hi I'm brie and I'm Nikki and we're The
Bella Twins and we're on this week's
episode of truth or death that's right
so check us out and see if we can handle
the heat
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans and welcome back
to another exciting episode of truth or
dab the hot one special where we give
our guests two simple options tell the
truth or suffer the wrath of the last
app and today I'm thrilled to welcome
the tag-team duo you know is brie and
Nikki Bella they're two of the most
iconic superstars in WWE history both
former Divas champions and on their way
to the WWE Hall of Fame and you can also
catch them in total Bella's Season 5
which is set to premiere this spring on
the e Network brie Nikki welcome to the
show
thank you we're excited and nervous and
excited
do you guys seek out spicy food do you
go there we actually do well yeah but
you know we turn into a party of four
because we're pregnant it's like it's
and taste buds have changed right um so
Tabasco is just not what it used to be
so let me explain this situation in
front of you guys have three scorching
hot chicken wings that have all been
doused in various versions of the last
dab of a set of deeply personal
potentially awkward questions for each
of you and when I ask you a question you
have a choice answer it honestly or
escape the truth by eating a death wing
and Nikki we'll start with you we'll
stay on the topic of wings because I
know that you worked a stint at Hooters
long yeah as a WWE Superstar
is there a Hooters trade secret that you
can divulge to the Internet I'll take
anything from sneaky upsell tactics to
the confidential wing recipe I've gotta
give us something okay so um we were
taught that whenever you were taking the
customers order so you would have to
lean in and you squeeze your cleavage
and then you'd have to be like what do
you want price with that cuz you know at
Hooters we would charge for fries and
ranches and blue cheese so the trick was
when you were up selling them for all
these little things are like fifty nine
cents
you had to lean on the table and squeeze
your breasts together Wow yeah what
taught me that um well I wore the
chicken cutlets before I got the fake
ones but yeah they all taught me that
Brie on to you you know from the
e-series and your youtube vlogs it's
clear that you're very comfortable
putting your life out there but I have
to imagine that not everything makes it
to camera what's one storyline or scene
from total Bellas that got cut made its
way to the cutting room floor because
there's either too embarrassing or too
raw for public consumption oh geez
let me think about this one on a brie
mode mode drunken moments now those all
made it I actually have to say one that
was really raw but um for some reason
they cut it and I was really bummed is
when my sister was like right after her
breakup we made this trip to Palm
Springs and it was like I thought a
great sister trip a lot of Tears but I
think we got too deep on that trip too
many tears not I'm jinx yeah that's what
it was we didn't have one drink and we
just cried we didn't get Real Housewives
on him so that Palm Springs trip has
never been shown and I was pretty sad
about that and it will forever remain a
mystery
on to the next round brie when we had
Stone Cold Steve Austin on the show he
taught us a lot of wrestling slang like
cheap heat or sending receipts on the
topic of the latter have you ever
intentionally targeted somebody with a
strike as a way to send a message or to
write a perceived wrong no I haven't I'm
a good person
I actually I am there I've wanted to
I've wanted to give many receipts
because people have intentionally hit me
in ways that I was like oh we're very
honest girls we don't dab tell the truth
well we'll see about that
and your years of touring the globe with
the WWE is there a city that you'll go
on record as saying here on truth or dab
has the worst wrestling fans in the
entire world you're probably gonna wanna
eat number one great um I'm gonna dab
into this so I just take a bite take a
bite
I'm so nervous for you so much [ __ ] Oh
Jerry fire right yeah I had the tongue
and it's like whoa oh my god
immediately you could so great who can
separate she can have some that's why we
put it on the table it's not just a set
yeah oh [ __ ]
very steep ramp up here on truther Deb
Nikki believe you will focus the
attention on your sister brie here Oh
brie you guys have always said that your
sisters first and business partners
second but I imagine that has to be
difficult especially when your careers
are so entwined when you think back on
it what's the furthest you guys have
been apart on a business decision more
specifically what's the biggest check
you've ever had to turn down because you
couldn't get your sister on board mmm oh
no one well usually she can't ever get
me on board and it always has to deal
with fast food chains
I better think fast I'm never really on
board with her and I've denied jobs that
take money out of her pocket do I have
to eat I think that would be only fair
you know if you take the money out of
the pocket to join you know to hop on
board in this way
this isn't factory farming that's what I
took out of her pocket
no bulan tiny the finest here untruth oh
yeah I'm so scared I'm versatile I don't
believe in factory farming thank you
well for the Paycheck I look like you're
going so I wanted to a car wash for
Carl's jr. she is
[ __ ] yeah uncle hot one that's terrible
how do people even enjoy that I'm trying
to oh oh yeah Nikki I know we like to
pretend that everything's good but I
know that the backstage politics and
competition especially in professional
wrestling it can be rough
can you out a superstar who presents
themselves as a heroic babyface in the
ring oh yeah but behind the scenes is a
ruthless bully server knows before I dab
I want you because there are bullies but
I'm not gonna name names I think if I'd
taken the high road yeah not gonna point
the finger cuz at some points back or
something like that I don't even know
cuz it's my tongue is gonna burn off
this really hard who is this for you
bullies I'm protecting I can't believe
it but hopefully you'll change your ways
you know who you are you definitely know
who you are I think I just felt my baby
kick my baby woke up that wasn't that
bad once you're in the fire you know oh
my gosh nope
spoke a little bit too soon it happens
here on truth or dab I think mountain
helps brie oh yes as we mentioned up top
you and your sister you're on your way
to the WWE Hall of Fame hypothetically
though I'm curious if there were only
one spot open who do you think's more
deserving your sister or your husband
four-time WWE Champion Daniel Bryan no
offense
oh I'm gonna go for my husband Bryan oh
my gosh I broke my neck in the ring I
have to brain I don't know if it's the
spice talking but Bryan
just had a lot of injuries we shared a
womb
I'm your same his journey and everything
he's accomplished Nikki the lore
surrounding Vince McMahon and the quirks
they're the stuff of legend from his
addiction to ketchup and mustard to the
internet rumors of firing people for
sneezing in his vicinity if you were
mentoring a young wrestler what are
three things that you would tell him or
her before their first meeting with
Vince so that they could avoid Vince's
wrath I'd actually tell them to be
extremely honest because my experience
with bits Vince and I came and talked oh
my god
my experience that when you're really
honest to actually get the best version
of Bin's appreciate his ideas and do
them I had to say die in the womb and I
don't want to to hurt but I did it and
don't sneeze words to live by
moving on here to the final round Bri
from talking to wrestlers over the years
this seems like there's oftentimes some
turbulence between the narrative or the
angle that they're supposed to play
looking back on your decade plus career
what's been your least favorite
storyline and then a follow up to that
when you were pitted against your sister
was that difficult or was it cathartic
in a weird way
I won't take do you think our babies are
dancing and our woman straight though
really hot gonna grow up to take my job
you know I feel like this is like the
beginning of a comment maybe or
something or I'm gonna give birth to a
dragon it's gonna spit fire at me when
it comes out other dragons but all right
final question here at truth are Deb
stumbling to the finish line Nikki can
you rank the following superstars on the
likelihood that they'll join you guys in
the Hall of Fame one day from most
likely to least likely okay friend of
the brand Sasha banks Becky Lynch Ronda
Rousey Paige double occurs on my nose
cuz I love you girls they have a booger
that sucks
I just don't like I have a better show
nose is running it like this is over
here okay in what a way to close it out
WWE Hall of Famers Tag Team Champions
and look at them tag teaming the wings
of death here on truth or dab Nikki Brie
is there anything that you want to say
to the internet before we get you out of
here this is really hot you're welcomed
all of you I protected know you like it
we didn't call your asses out said we
took the heat yeah you guys brought the
heat you know you are
I've got good job good job that's so hot
okay I'll give you that huge trick no
wait hot that hey what's going on hot
ones fans this is Sean Evans and as you
know you can catch me every Thursday in
this little black box interviewing
celebrities but what if I told you that
there was a show that actually had a
decent set where we fed even hotter
wings to civilians while asking them
trivia questions well guess what my
friend that show exists and it's called
hot ones the game show hot ones the game
show on truTV check your local listings
we'll see you in the pepper dome
[Music]